the u.s housing market is in big trouble
and it is issuing a major warning sign
charlie bolillo pointing out the u.s new
home sales have hit a 26-month low in
june that is down 43 from their 2020
high as he says this tends to be a
leading indicator for the economy and
recession odds continue to rise the
structure of the real estate market is
important to understand first
transactions plummet and then with a lag
prices start to decline we're just
entering that second phase as we watch
the median price of a new home down 12
percent over the last two months that's
the lowest level since june of 2021
charlie eloquently points out that many
have been dismissive of the historic
collapse and affordability over the past
year but he believes that's the primary
factor driving lower demand fewer
transactions and now price declines the
housing market is incredibly important
to pay attention to it's one of the
biggest purchases that people make and
many times it's the largest financial
asset that they have on their personal
balance sheet as we're watching less
transactions get done and the price of
homes come down it tells us that there
could be even worse economic times ahead
now one of the major x factors in all of
this analysis is what the federal
reserve is going to do for the last
eight months they've been talking about
destroying demand and housing showing
that they're being successful but
inflation is still persistently high at
over nine percent and so we've entered a
stagflationary period
gdp growth in q1 was negative it's
likely to be negative in q2 housing
prices look like they're in a free fall
and there is no point at which they're
going to pivot until the fed decides to
change their mind the federal reserve is
in control and they are destroying the
u.s housing market until they pivot and
until they go back to a loose monetary
policy regime don't expect for there to
be any changes
as we head deeper and deeper into a
recessive period and the economic
outlook gets more dire in the next six
to 12 months you need to be prepared
ensure that you've got a strong balance
sheet ensure that you're optimizing for
cash flow make sure that you're putting
yourself in a position so that you can
survive the bad times which will allow
you to thrive when we get to the other
side